I think 590 characters that I need to
start building up they're all tanks so I
have a monk tank death knight tank druid
tank paladin tank I think my warriors
not quite max level I think I have a
ninety in some other class but at any
rate I like tanking on every class that
it's available to before I don't do DPS
or healing in any class now I've ever
have you ever thought about playing
World of Tanks no no I I did actually
play World of Tanks for a little bit but
it's a little bit different
for people who don't know who you are
who are you hi Matthew Rory product
manager for calm fun and giantbomb I do
a lot of behind the scenes stuff support
community management store stuff
basically everything else that that none
of the energy really have time to do
coffee I don't get out people drink
coffee coffee so where's the man who was
drinking Bastion and you also play a
hell a bunch of why apparently off and
on for the last 10 years I think I
started around four or five months
before the game came out so I was
working for GameSpot at the time
freelancing doing game guides when I
know I put freelancing in quotes
I was actually freelancing and my editor
at the time gave me a hookup for the
friends-and-family alpha I think we were
all on Ner'zhul I believe it was you
know definitely some people could you
get here at 8:00 a.m. and like you're
here early and they would look at you
like oh I never went home a lot of
sleeping in the office around that time
it came out during you know the end of
the year where we had to do all our game
of the Year stuff so a lot of people
spent a lot of time and there was fierce
debate about that getting game of the
year I remember but a lot of people were
behind it I think it event eventually
did
you've been playing on and off for the
past ten years what was your sort of
most I guess what was the most impactful
expansionpak do you think for me it was
Wrath of the Lich King I definitely
found that that was my favorite ones
because I normally play as a tank which
is a character that kind of has to
absorb a bunch of hits and make sure
nobody else in your team is getting hit
and they've had a lot of iterative
design decisions with tanks over the
years before wrath it was kind of you
didn't really do much damage as a tank
you just kind of put out threat and
threat is what makes people attack you
so it wasn't it was fun to do you're
still getting hit a bunch but you
weren't actually really contributing a
lot to the fights are just kind of like
make sure you don't die but then wrath
kind of turned that on his head a reduce
the amount of threat that takes two but
they really up the damage and what they
did the enemies so you would actually
keep the monsters attention on you by
doing huge amounts of damage which was
really fun
obviously um giving in guilds on and off
and it was really fun to play with those
people in dungeons as well but
eventually I think it was around the
time of Rafi added the looking
group tool which is kind of a random
queue thing you can just plop in your
roll I'm going to do a dungeon we do
this dungeon or that dungeon and I want
the tank or healer a DPS and it would
automatically make a group for you and
plop you into the dungeon and warp you
right back out at the end so it took
away a lot of the difficulty in terms of
finding your group used to have to sit
around cities like hey who wants to do
this dungeon just type around for half
an hour trying to find a group and then
inevitably somebody drop out in the
first five minutes it was a real
nightmare so looking for group tool I
know a lot of people complain about what
it did to communities and server
communities and stuff like that but for
me it was if I wanted to go out and take
half an hour or an hour of my time I
wanted to get I could log in as a tank
could the queues are really short
because they're not as many tanks as
there are other roles so I would log in
get into a group and play for you know
two three dungeons and just kind of pop
right back down go on my merry way just
walk away from my computer without
having to worry too much about it so it
was a primarily born of convenience I
wanted to do what I would like to do and
I liked playing five mana dungeons a lot
I liked Solon as well like doing almost
everything that game but I really
enjoyed playing five and dungeons and
tanking was kind of a way to do that
more easily but then once I started
doing it more and more it became kind of
a psychological thing to I enjoyed being
the kind of person in the game who had
to be it's hard to describe really what
it is
metaphysically or whatever but you're
the person who the entire group kind of
depends on to not wipe not waste
everybody's time so you have to be very
competent as a tank to actually get
through a lot of these dungeons but it
was a way to take on responsibilities in
a game that I really hadn't explored too
much before I play a lot of multiplier
games but those are generally you're
part of a big big team and you're kind
of one cog in a fat a machine but
tanking has always been kind of the a
weird way to become take on
responsibilities that I don't normally
look for in either real-life or other
games
it's a weird role it's like in sports it
to be like in football or soccer the the
goalkeeper or goalkeeper the pitcher
kind of you're out there on an island
and you have to be good at what you do
we also have to rely on your teammates
and it's always been something that kind
of fascinates me just kind of being the
person who is going to be got my shield
you can hit it as much as you want but
you're not going to get these guys back
here no matter how terrible they are
not everybody really wants to do that
now to ever fix us fun but I really
think it's fun and rewards now or just I
can pop in and play a dungeon without
having to wait like even 30 seconds as
opposed to right now with Drano right
here
DPS queues are like an apple or
sometimes so yeah it seems like it's a
great looking expansion I'm really
enjoying the garrison stuff and I'm
really looking forward to taking time
this usually after Christmas that
Christmas week is when I play for about
80 hours so I'm looking forward to
clocking that time